this reminds me of longing versus want
in your book you mentioned longing is a
unification a stretching out to but want
is a desire which puts you it separate
from
yes is there a connection or is that
just in my head
no
i'm delighted that you made that
connection i think it's it's exactly
right
from my point of view
and in fact there is um
if people are interested if you
if you google mcgill chris longing and
one thing i think it's called
i gave an hour-long talk um
in london
about four years ago on the distinction
between longing and wanting
and
nowadays it seems to me that we have
lost the sense
of a longing for something to which we
already feel an attraction and which is
calling to us and which we are
we are sort of uh
rather
blind way trying to to reach towards but
constant reaching out to instead we have
once you know i don't that that you get
to put it in your little bag of stuff
what do you want in a relationship you
even say that
well
i think these words all have their
meaning and they all have their value
and they they will have their place but
but no i think there was a very i mean
it's fascinating the word long literally
comes from an anglo-saxon rude langian
which means to stretch out
something that is
gone from you but which you are still
connected you want to reconnect with in
fact it is this
sisterly and diastole if you like which
are from the heartbeat you know the
sisterly followed by the diastole the
lup followed by the top there's this
kind of contraction and release is the
way in which movement happens in nature
by alternations of that kind produce
something that is just a kind of
addition of the two in some neutral way
or a or perhaps a compromise of 50 50.
it produces something completely new
this is the point it is the creation the
creativity of your life of this world of
the cosmos depends on our ability to see
that opposites
need to be held together
the world is not as simple as we think
it is things that we think are good
also can seem kill something that is bad
the things that we think are bad also
conceal something that is good and we
need to finesse these things in order to
find our way in the world
that what i mean by the opposition
bringing something new into being is the
tension of a string of a guitar or a
violin
it's important for that that it's pulled
in two directions at once in fact if it
weren't pulled in two directions at once
it wouldn't work you might say well
that's a waste of energy why pull things
in two directions at once why not come
to an agreement and a compromise and
just stop pulling well then you don't
have a string anymore you don't have a
violin anymore you don't have any music
anymore
well something comes out of that
conflict which is very important sorry
to be fair in string theory you can have
closed loop strings and you just give
them attention it's just like a variable
you vary oh i i really wasn't um uh uh
pretending to talk about a string theory
i don't really don't understand it i
know okay
when you say that you're like
we need to we're separate but we're also
together and this impulse to be
separated should be there and the
impulse to be together should be there
we should be guided by the together one
more so than the separate one that's the
individuality
okay well that to me it
reminds me is i i'm not meaning this by
the way can i just say i'm not meaning
this principally or only uh to do with
social relations i'm thinking of it as
a metaphysical structural feature of
reality that it has this structure of
the need for difference and togetherness
not just we as human beings have it